cette seconde rencontre aristote cette
seconde c'est vraiment rien bon on a
quand même les économiser 7 secondes
il paraît que c'est la durée de la
première impression vous rencontrez une
nouvelle personne est au bout de sept
secondes vous avez déjà une opinion
arrêté sur elle mais le plus important
le plus frappant aussi c'est que cette
première impression forgé en seulement
sept secondes va influencer fortement
votre rapport avec cette personne c'est
un effet psychologique qui s'appelle le
biais de confirmation
l'esprit humain cherche toujours à
confirmer ses premières impressions
on vous sourit vous allez remarquer en
priorité les marques de sympathie
on vous manifeste de l'hostilité vous
serez aveugle à toute manifestation de
sympathie parce que vous vous focalisez
sur ce qui confirme votre première
impression
pourquoi est-ce que je vous explique sa
est pourquoi est-ce que je parle du
biais de confirmation
je vous enfin parce que l'introduction
de la dissertation créer un biais de
confirmation chez le correcteur si elle
est conforme à ses attentes
alors il situera consciemment ou
inconsciemment votre copie dans une
fourchette de notes haute cuisine
remarquera en priorité dans la suite du
devoir les éléments qui confirment sont
a priori positif inversement si
l'introduction ne fait pas le job
alors vous créez un biais de
confirmation négative ce qui veut dire
que le correcteur remarquera tous les
petits défauts de votre copie détaille
qu'il aurait négligé après une bonne
introduction en clair étant donné le
biais de confirmation réussir
l'introduction est crucial pour réussir
la dissertation je vais donc vous donner
les trois secrets pour réussir
l'introduction de la dissertation
je vais pas vous expliquer dans le
détail comment faire une introduction
parce que j'ai un cours gratuit de
méthodologie qui vous explique tout de a
à z avec des schémas cd exemple vous
pouvez vous aussi recevoir mon cours
gratuits de méthodologie de la
dissertation soit en cliquant sur le
lien qui s'affiche en haut à droite soit
sur celui qui est dans la description de
cette vidéo
inscrivez-vous et vous m'en direz des
nouvelles
après le moyen le plus rapide de réussir
l'introduction de dissertation c'est de
regarder cette vidéo parce que je vais
vous révéler trois secrets pour rédiger
une correction qui plaisent aux
correcteurs n'importe quel correct
regardez bien la vidéo jusqu'au bout
parce que je vais vous donner des
techniques précises à appliquer dès
votre prochain devoirs et surtout ne
manquez pas à la fin de la vidéo parce
que je vous dévoile les astuces de style
que je réserve normalement à mes élèves
à les premiers secrets pour réussir
l'introduction de la dissertation atamu
aristote il n'y a pas de définition dans
son introduction
c'est fou ça tout le monde sait qu'il
faut définir les termes du sujet dans
l'introduction en bois les jumelles 6e
on va se balader
[Musique]
c'est ce qui risque de vous arriver si
vous ne définit c'est pas les termes du
sujet premier secret c'est donc plus
généralement de respecter toutes les
conventions méthodologique de
l'introduction de la dissertation
alors qu'est ce que je veux dire par
convention les conventions ce sont les
éléments que le correcteur s'attend à
trouver dans votre traduction je vous
rappelle que la dissertation est un
exercice scolaire ce qui veut dire que
l'introduction réussie si et seulement
si elle plaît aux correcteurs or le
correcteur c'est un peu le gardien de
l'orthodoxie
c'est à dire qu'il considère qu'il ya
une bonne manière de rédiger une
dissertation avec des consignes de base
et s'attend à ce qu'elle soit suivre
maintenant quelles sont ces conventions
le correcteur s'attend à trouver quatre
choses dans l'introduction de la
dissertation
tout d'abord une accroche une amorce ce
sont comme vous le savez probablement
les toutes premières phrases de la
dissertation qui servent d'eux objectif
capter l'attention du lecteur et
démontré un intérêt pour le sujet
manière un peu artificielle c'est vrai
alors je sais que certains profs disent
qu'on peut se dispenser de ses phrases
accroche et ça peut se défendre
les honnêtement on ne vous demande pas
la lune non plus et puis commencer
l'introduction de la dissert actions
directement par la définition des termes
du sujet c'est à dire par la partie la
plus chiante à lire je ne pense pas que
ça met le correcteur de bonne humeur
donc mon conseil c'est de prendre la
peine de rédiger une accroche ce qui
n'est pas forcément compliqué avec les
bonnes techniques et un bon entraînement
deuxième chose que le correcteur
s'attend à voir dans l'introduction de
la dissertation et bien
ce qui était absent la dissertation que
j'ai montré aristote la définition des
termes du sujet ça honnêtement tous les
profs le répète dans toutes les matières
ils ont 200 % raison ils ont bien raison
parce que c'est impossible de réfléchir
avec rigueur sont définir les termes du
problème intellectuel
le philosophe thomas ça hop a montré que
c'est souvent le laxisme dans la
définition des termes qui est à
l'origine des raisonnements délirant
donc si vous ne voulez pas louper le
sujet défini cc terme et présenter les
définitions dans l'introduction
troisième chose que le correcteur
s'attend à voir dans l'introduction de
la dissertation la problématique voyage
que c'est la problématique c'est la
question unique situé à la fin de
l'introduction
elles servent à exprimer le problème
intellectuel que vous allez résoudre
dans la dissertation
c'est vrai qu'elle peut être difficile à
formuler cette question mais le
correcteur n'atteint pas de la grande
littérature
il veut juste comprendre le problème
intellectuel que vous posez s'il ne l'y
aucune question à la fin de votre
introduction c'est grave parce que le
but de la dissertation c'est précisément
de résoudre un problème intellectuel
disserter sans problématique c'est un
peu comme jouer au foot sans ballon
personnellement je ne vois pas trop
l'intérêt quatrième et dernière chose
que le correcteur s'attend à voir dans
l'introduction de la dissertation
l'annnonce de plans alors l annonce de
plan n'est pas exactement dans
l'introduction parce qu'il faut sauter
une ligne après la problématique mais en
pratique on en parle dans la
méthodologie de l'introduction comme
pour la croche je sais que certains
profs demande de ne pas annoncer le plan
et ça aussi ça peut se défendre mais
c'est inutile de se prendre la tête pour
ça je réponds toujours aux élèves dans
100% ou dans 99% des meilleures copies
on trouve une annonce de plan donc
terminée l'introduction de vaud
dissertation par une annonce de voilà
j'en ai terminé avec les quatre
conventions attendu par les correcteurs
pour réussir l'introduction de la
dissertation vous devez les respecter
vous n'avez pas le choix parce que le
correcteur c'est votre arbitre c'est lui
et lui seul qui décide de vous mettre
une bonne note
ou pas donc si vous le contrarier dès le
début de l'altercation s'est mal va vous
créez un biais de confirmation négatif
et inversement respectant toutes les
conventions de l'introduction de la
dissertation vous montrer le correcteur
que vous
jouer le jeu et vous vous le mettez dans
la poche mais pour ça vous pouvez faire
encore mieux regardez cette introduction
est ce que vous avez envie de la lire
vraiment on a mal à la tête après deux
phrases or il ya une chose simple que
l'élève aurait pu faire pour faciliter
la lecture n'avait pas une
eh bien il aurait pu subdiviser son
introduction en plusieurs paragraphes
ce qui veut dire en pratique a ajouté un
alinéa au début de chaque partie de
l'introduction de la dissertation de
deuxième secret pour réussir votre
réduction de la dissertation
c'est donc de là subdivisée en
paragraphes c'est un moyen facile et
immédiat de faciliter la lecture du
correcteur et ça ça n'est pas
négligeable parce que la correction est
une tâche pénible
et oui mettez vous à la place du
correcteur il doit corriger des textes
qui sont d'un niveau médiocre par
rapport à son niveau à lui qui est un
expert de la matière il ne lit pas pour
son plaisir personnel et il ne choisit
pas ce qu'il y ajoutez à cela le fait
que les dissertations sont toutes sur le
même sujet et enfin il n'en corrige pas
seulement quelques-unes des plus tôt des
dizaines voire des centaines
donc c'est une tâche répétitive avec un
gros volet pour ces raisons que je viens
d'énumérer vous avez fortement intérêt à
faciliter la lecture du correcteur est
la meilleure manière de le faire c'est
de subdiviser l'introduction de la
dissertation en plusieurs paragraphes
après comment faire plus précisément ce
que je vous recommande c'est de
consacrer un paragraphe entier à chaque
enjeu de l'introduction passera beaucoup
plus claire pour le correcteur du coup
quels sont les enjeux de l'introduction
je pense que vous ayez connaissent et il
y en a quatre
les deux premiers se sont la croche la
définition des termes du sujet dont j'ai
déjà parlé
ensuite il y à la problématisation la
partie l'introduction dans laquelle vous
expliquer le point de départ de votre
réflexion
c'est à dire l'idée qui vous a mené aux
problèmes intellectuels à résoudre dans
la dissertation
donc là on est au 3e paragraphe
quatrième et dernier enjeu c'est la
problématique que j'ai est également
évoqué ça veut dire que la question
constitue à elle seule un unique
paragraphe
ça peut sembler bizarre mais ça ne pose
aucun problème mais surtout ça permet
aux correcteurs qui est souvent pressés
d'identifier immédiatement votre
problématique
enfin il reste encore l' annonce de plan
mais elle constitue de toute manière
la grave puisqu'elle est séparé de
l'introduction par un solide voici à
quoi ressemble la structure idéale d'une
introduction de dissertation davantage
avec cette structure c'est que le
correcteur s'est immédiatement où il en
est dans la lecture vous êtes
transparent avec lui vous lui faciliter
la tâche
et ça il vous en sera reconnaissant
quand il décidera de votre note
mais si vous voulez qu'ils aiment votre
introduction vous devez appliquer le
troisième et dernier secret regardez
bien la vidéo jusqu'au bout parce que je
vais vous dévoiler les astuces de style
que je réserve normalement mais elle est
ce que vous lisez des rapports de jeu et
moi oui souvent même ça me permet de
savoir exactement ce que les correcteurs
valorise ce qu'ils aiment et ce qu'ils
n'aiment pas dans une dissertation la
qualité de la langue et de l'expression
constitue une exigence primordiale du
jury ça c'est une phrase tirée du
rapport du jury de la dissertation de
français du concours de polytechnique de
mais tous les rapports disent la même
chose si c'est bien écrit c'est mieux
notés et c'est bien normal parce que
c'est le but de l'exercice de les
dissertations vérifier le niveau
d'expression écrite de l'élève
alors là vous pouvez me dire d'accord
mais qu'est ce que ça change pour
l'introduction en particulier eh bien il
faut penser à la correction pour
comprendre
l'introduction et la partie de la
dissertation que le correcteur lie avec
le plus de soin ou disons plutôt le
moins rapidement du coup si vous voulez
le convaincre de la qualité de votre
expression écrite et bien c'est dans
l'introduction que ça joue en général le
correcteur regarde le développement
plutôt en diagonale a en tout cas moins
attentivement mais l'introduction hilali
vraiment parce que ça lui permet de se
faire rapidement une idée de votre
niveau et vous situer dans une
fourchette de notes
alors maintenant comment écrire pour
plaire aux correcteurs est ce qu'il faut
faire du pouce ou du platon évidemment
que non pas besoin de viser le prix
nobel de littérature bien au contraire
il vaut mieux éviter
en fait vous devez toujours cherché la
même chose faciliter la lecture du
correcteur et pour ce faire vous devez
écrire clairement qu'est ce que ça veut
dire écrire clairement ça veut dire que
le lecteur vous comprend immédiatement
il n'a pas besoin de faire un effort
d'essayer de deviner ce que vous voulez
dire
il n'hésite pas
le sens de vos phrases et transparent
alors maintenant vous connaissez le
principe et je vais vous donner trois
astuces pour écrire plus clairement
la première c'est de faire attention à
la longueur des phrases plus une phrase
est longue moins il a de chances d'être
clair vous avez donc intérêt à rédiger
des phrases plus et assure ça ne veut
pas dire vous devez enchaîner les
slogans arrêt que vous pouvez suivre
c'est de mettre un point dès que vous
pensez que c'est possible après vous
écrirez forcément des phrases plus ou
moins longue selon ce que vous voulez
dire ce que vous pouvez faire à cet
égard c'est d'essayer d'alterner les
phrases courtes et les phrases - courte
c'est un moyen facile de créer du
dynamisme et donc de capter l'attention
du lecteur deuxième astuces pour écrire
plus clairement utilisé un lien logique
dans chaque phrase pour la lier à la
précédente en fr ainsi dès lors hors en
revanche cependant et c'est ça sera
peut-être difficile au début mais ça va
vous forcer à développer vos idées avec
fluidité puis surtout ça va faciliter la
lecture du correcteur puisqu'il sera
immédiatement envoyé un lien logique le
rapport entre la phrase et la précédente
certains disent que ça n'est pas très
subtil certes mais le correcteur ne fait
pas une lecture subtil de la copie ce
n'est pas comme quand il lit de la
poésie en terrasse d'un café
je voulais déjà expliqué il corrige de
manière expéditive
il va à l'essentiel donc il faut lui
montrer grossièrement les qualités de
l'expression écrite troisième et
dernière astuce pour écrire plus
clairement évité le jargon jargon c'est
le vocabulaire technique propre à la
matière dans laquelle vous disserter
c'est par exemple ontologie en
philosophie anticipations rationnelles
en économie habitus en sociologie etc
mon conseil est concernant l' usage de
ces mots c'est si vous n'êtes pas sûr de
bien connaître leur sens et où si vous
les utilisez pas naturellement dans la
conversation
alors ne les utilisez pas en
dissertation parce que ce que vous
risquez de faire c'est de vous dénoncez
vous même de révéler votre incompétence
et surtout de compliquer le propos parce
que vous ne maîtrisez pas les nuances du
concept utilisé donc exclusivement les
mots que vous comprenez n'essayez pas
passer pour un expert pour impressionner
le correcteur voilà en résumé si vous
faites attention à la longueur des
phrases si vous insérez un lien
logique chaque phrase et si vous évitez
le jargon vous rendrez votre expression
écrite beaucoup plus clair et donc vous
marquerez des points dans l'esprit du
correcteur si en plus vous respecter les
conventions
si vous consacrez un paragraphe à chaque
enjeu alors là l'introduction
dissertation a de bonnes chances de
plaire aux correcteurs mais là j'y pense
il ya peut-être un quatrième secret en
fait le quatrième secret c'est que vous
avez besoin d'une bonne méthode de
dissertation pour réussir l'introduction
bah oui parce que la qualité de
l'introduction découle de la qualité de
la problématisation qui découle de la
qualité de l'analyse du sujet etc bref
tout est lié dans la dissertation donc
si vous réussissez les premières étapes
vous avez plus de chances de réussir les
suivantes dont la rédaction de
l'introduction n'est pas vraiment un
secret mais les élèves oublie souvent
les connexions entre les différentes
opérations intellectuelle et
rédactionnelles de l'exercice de la
dissertation pour acquérir une bonne
méthode de dissertation et ainsi réussir
toutes les étapes de l'exercice je vous
invite à vous inscrire pour recevoir mon
cours gratuits de méthodologie de la
dissertation soit en cliquant sur le
lien qui sapent fiche maintenant ou à
droite soit celui qui est dans la
description de la vidéo si vous avez des
questions sur l'introduction de la
dissertation n'hésitez pas à me les
poser dans les commentaires et j'y
répondrai sans faute
je suis romain je suis toujours avec mon
fidèle aristote et vous étiez sur mille
idées que général rappelez vous n'avez
pas besoin de vous prendre la tête pour
réussir l'introduction de la
dissertation
[Musique]
oh